do you think they'll ever
come out god i hope so i mean
i hope everybody ultimately will yeah i
i hope
everybody will ultimately see
things more clearly than they can
when they're sitting inside the bubble
of scientology
um you know including my own children
and but it's hard
it's a hard thing to do and ultimately
in my experience what happens is
there is some straw that breaks the
camel's back
and some it's it's not that someone
comes along
and tells you scientology is bad or this
is bad or that's bad it's some personal
experience
that you go through and you go
wait a minute you can't convince one
person can't convince
another person it has to happen from
inside exactly
you can then if they're questioning or
they have doubts or they're wondering
what's going on
you can then give them information and
that often helps
like that's what happened with leah i
mean leah was like
i don't get with this and this doesn't
make sense and blah blah blah
now you're saying this stuff about these
people that i know
me being one of them and she called me
before she left scientology she called
me and she said
i want to know what's true right what
was the straw that
broke the camel's back for her um the
incident with at the wedding of tom
cruise and
and katie holmes where she asked where's
shelley
where's shelley is david miscavige's
wife who's been disappeared
for more than a decade and nobody has
heard from her or seen her
really and she was at the wedding asking
a bunch of people
hey where she i guess she was at the
table with she was at the table
and asked asked actually tommy davis who
was
the at that time he had
taken over from me as the international
spokesperson of scientology and he was
like
the uh the
handler for tom cruise and she asked
tommy davis
and that's when he famously said you
don't have the [ __ ] rank to ask
and that then resulted in her being
ordered to come to clearwater and scrub
toilets and that's what she was doing
yeah
undergo uh expensive
sec checking which is interrogation on
the scientology e-meter
that she paid 300 000 for and
then she never got
answers and nobody would ever answer her
and that just sort of that's not a good
thing to do with leah
not like she's just his dude that is
insane
when she gets onto something she just
does not
stop and so she ultimately just said you
know what
[ __ ] you people i'm out of here i'm i'm
not dealing with this anymore
you won't tell me the truth i'm not
um gonna participate and then this is
after she gave three hundred thousand
dollars yep
she got that back oh really yep
how would you choose unusually no she
went uh david miscavige tried to
handle her and part of his handling was
saying yeah that was all a mistake that
shouldn't have been done
the people that did that were all bad
and here's you know i'm going to give
you your money back
wow that seems unlikely
it's very unlikely it's very unusual and
it's only that sort of treatment is
reserved
for celebrities in scientology
scientology celebrities get
very different treatment than the
run-of-the-mill
suckers scientology the the celebrities
get a discount right
no no sometimes they get shipped for
free but they don't get a discount
they're expected to pay
i mean paying is how much did you pay
nothing i was a sea org member so i get
everything so york membership members
don't pay but people who participate in
scientology that
aren't employees do not pay yeah
the regular customers do pay and you
know
it's a it's a strongly held religious
belief
that you must pay for anything that you
get in order to be
in exchange and that if you're not in
exchange you want
you know benefit will accrue to you from
that which you
get for free okay so so
where do you think susan is miscavigi's
wife shelly
oh oh shelley her name was shelley yeah
that's michelle
michelle and that's leah was questioning
where she was yeah
where do i think is where she might be
yeah she's at a property that
is one of these secret churches
spiritual technology
locations that is up in
the san bernardino mountains in southern
california
in fact one of the episodes of the
aftermath i went up there
and this pi jumped out of the woods and
started like filming me and going
what are you doing here she's being held
prisoner up there
well or prisoners
believe a slave rather prison of belief
it's the same thing you know yes there's
barbed wire fences and cameras
and lights and motion sensors etc etc
around that property just like there is
at gold and that is a way of
deterring people from trying to jump the
fence or escape
but that's not what really keeps i mean
if you
want to get out you can't
and plenty of people have proven that i
mean valerie
haney escaped in the trunk of a car from
gold
from that from that property because she
wanted to
who is valerie she is she appeared on
the aftermath
and she was one of david miscavige's
assistants okay
or shelley miscavige's personal
assistant actually
and so shelley is
there because she believes that
she is somehow in the wrong or
was in the wrong or perhaps she believes
that
she is waiting for elrond hubbard to
return
still and that when he comes back
then everything will be sorted out
because
she was with l ron hubbard long before
david miscavige ever showed up
was she she was when i arrived on the
apollo
shelly was there and she was like 12 or
13 i guess and she and her sister
clarice
were worked directly for l ron hubbard
they were his messengers
they ran around the ship taking
hubbard would say go tell the engineer
to you know
turn the heat on the the fans and then
run down tell the engineer and
so she was a long-term
very loyal hubbard
acolyte okay and i assume
remains that way to this day just like
hubbard's daughter i mean hubbard's
eldest daughter is still there diana
like all the rest of his kids they're
not in scientology at all
they're all gone they're what do you
mean they're gone
well they left are they still they're
still alive well
two of them are okay no three of them
but two of them were in the sea
organization you know one of them was a
very good friend of mine suzette
his his second daughter she was like the
maid of honor at my wedding to kathy
and she left the sea org
oh i don't know long 10 or 15 years ago
i guess and the youngest son
arthur left the seog a long time ago
and the eldest
son of hubbard and mary sue quentin
committed suicide
because he was gay and being gay in
scientology as a big no-no
and diana is still there
and is i guess hoping that hubbard will
come back
god i would freaking die to have a
conversation with one of his kids
oh yeah that would be great holy [ __ ] to
hear some of the stories of growing up
having him as a dad yeah
god damn so what is uh
like the grip here in clear water
especially downtown clearwater with
scientology
seems to be relentless and it seems like
clearwater cannot escape this tight grip
of scientology it's been dead for so
long i know scientology owns a lot of
the real estate around there but what is
the deal with
and there's people walking up and down
the streets 24 7 who
i don't know what they're doing where
they're going but
what is the deal with scientology and
downtown clearwater staying
the way it is well
that clear water is what scientology
calls
its spiritual headquarters clear water
is
the the um
the top of the scientology spiritual
organizational hierarchy it is not
the international management of
scientology around the world
that happens in los angeles or in
california
clearwater is the spiritual headquarters
but what that means is it's where all
the money is made
they make you know upwards of
two to three to four million dollars a
week
there and it
because because people come from all
over the world scientologists come from
all over the world from
auditing yep okay and ultimately you
have to come to clearwater
if you're a scientologist and you want
to go to the top of the scientology
bridge
okay you have to come to clearwater
and all of the the whales of scientology
that's their organization the people
that have
unlimited funds the bob duggans of the
world
who have you know hundreds of millions
of dollars
this is where they gravitate to